はいじゃあ3さんこんにちは
今日は
大人も知らない
自分の変え方という話をします
いつもは大人に向けて話していることなのでみんなにはちょっと難しいかなぁって思う
かもしれません
でも一生懸命お話をするので皆さんも一生懸命聞いてもらえると嬉しいです
それでは早速始めます
僕のお友達で
ブラキ君という人がいます
彼はとっても頑張り屋さんで今日のお話の主人公です
村木君は
みんなのお父さんお母さんと同じように夜遅くまで一生懸命お仕事をしています
で朝も早く起きてお仕事に向かって
夜遅くまでお仕事をしています
ある日村木君に会うと
通っても悲しそうな顔してました
どうしたのって村聞くに聞くと実は
お仕事を頑張りすぎちゃって
すごい疲れちゃったんですね村木君は
その結果どうなったかっていう風に言うと
村木君は
頭がねぇ
ハゲちゃったんですかっている
影になっちゃったんですねお仕事頑張りすぎちゃったんです
で
実の日に村聞く2アウト
村木君はもーっと悲しそうな顔してました
村木国どうしたのって聞くと実は
ハゲただけじゃなくて
お付き合いしていた恋人に禿げたせいで
フラれちゃったんですね
で
悲しくなって
村木君はたーーーくさんお菓子を食べたそうです
そうして太っちゃったんですねものすごく
村木君は
まあこそかわいそうだなと思って何とか助けてあげたいとお兄さん思いました
でもハゲたのを治すのは難しいです
恋人を作ってあげるのも難しいです
お兄さんは予防医学というみんなを健康にするお仕事をしています
だから村木君を
太ったムの樹くんを痩せて健康にすることはできるかなと思って
痩せるための通っておきの秘訣を教えてあげました
これまで偉い人たちがいっぱいいっぱい研究をして
痩せるためには
体を動かすか
あるいは食べ過ぎないことが大事ということがわかってきています
こういう話をすると村木君は
なるほど
いって
納得してくれました
ブラックもちょっとは子なんですねうーん
でも一生懸命ながら聞くんですで元々体を動かすのが好きだったので夜ジョギングを
することに
村聞くが決めました
そうすると
早速変化が起こります
村木君はよる仕事が遅いのに家に帰って一生懸命ジョギングしました
そうすると気に帰ると喉が渇いてます
冷蔵庫を開けて
ヒールを飲むようになりました
みんなも大人になったらわかると思うけどビールって美味しいんだよね
特に運動した後美味しいんです
ビールを飲むと何か食べたくなるんですね
村木君はジョギングの途中にコンビニに寄って
ポテトチップスを買ってくるようになりました
あららですね
痩せるためにジョギングしたのに
そうビールを飲んでポテトして食べるからもっとちゃったんです
これはひどいなということでちょっと違うことをやりましょうっていうふうに村木君と
相談しました
村木くんとお話すると村木君の1日は4労組奥までお仕事をしています
だから
朝から通っても疲れてるっていうふうに言います
夕食も沿いのでまだお腹にご飯が残ってて
朝ご飯も食べられないっていう風に言うんですね
で
そのまま会社に行くので午前中お腹が空いちゃってお仕事になりませんってもらって
いいます
午前中お腹すいてるもんだから
お昼は良い杯食べちゃうんですね
おかわりをいっぱいします
そうすると
午後からお腹いっぱいなりすぎちゃって
眠くなって仕事にならないですね
これ大人の世界では村木君は残念な人って言います
でようやく夕方から体が起きてきて
でそこから仕事を始める者だから当然遅くなるんですね
で実はこういう大人の背負ってすごい多いです
大人は子どもに向かって早く寝て早く起きろーって言うんですけど
大人は
遅くまで起きて
全然その元気なく1日を過ごしている人すごく多いです
で村木君は
夜
早く寝るようにしました
だけれども今まで早く寝たことがないから
寝ても寝ても夜だって言うんですね
が難しいんだと
どうしたらブラックも痩せられるのかということでもう1回考えてみました
その結果ですねー
村木この店車よくわかったのが
何が自分が変わりたいと思ったときに
僕たちは新しいことを突然始めようとします
村木君だったらジョギングしてみたり夜早く起きたりと
でも変わりたいと思って突然新しいことを始めてもなかなか続きません
なので新しいことをやるんじゃなくて
毎日やってることをちょこーっとだけ変えようっていう風に変えました
例えば村木君の一日を見てみると毎日やってること何があるかなって見てみたら
お昼に食べ過ぎることだったんですね
だからお昼に食べ過ぎるんじゃなくて
おかわりをあんまりせずにやめようと
そうすると午後から眠くならなくなったので
村木組む仕事が捗ったそうですそうするとお仕事が早く終わって夕食も早くなったので
家に早く帰るようになったんですね
で容量が早く帰れるようになったので夜も早く眠れるようになりました
そうすると村木君は朝お腹がすいて目が覚めるようになったそうです
これまでは目覚まし時計で頑張っておくしたんだけども
夕食が速いので朝グーッとお腹がすいて目が覚めるようになったそうです
で朝ごはんを食べるようになってちゃんとご飯を食べていくので午前中はお腹が空か
ないから仕事がはかどる
いう風に村木君は
お昼ごはんを食べ過ぎないようにすることで生活が全部変わっちゃったんですね
で
村木君はどなたかというと食べすぎないようになって時間もできるようになったので
村木君無事にダイエットが大成功しました
ありがとうございます
で痩せて仕事もできるようなった村木君が
女の子にモテないはずがありません
禿げててもいいよって言ってくれる彼女が出来て
水で今度ですね今度村木くんこの新しい恋人と結婚することになったそうです
こういうマークなら所以上でしまいなんですけれども最後に今日の話を振り返ってみ
たいと思います
大人も知らない自分の買い方
僕たちはやっぱりすごい人を見たりとかあるいは自分ってダメだなーって落ち込んだ
ときに自分を変えようと思うんですねその時に突然新しいことをやりだす人が多いです
でもそれはなかなか続かないっていうことが
いろんな研究の結果は買ってきました
新しいことを突然やるんじゃなくて毎日やっていることをちょこっと変えていくって
いうことが実は自分を変える上で一番確実で大きく自分を変える方法であるということ
がこれまたいろんな研究でわかってきました
その際にですね自分が毎日やってることってたくさんあるんですね
どれを変えたらいいんだっていう時は
1日全体が変わるようなことはないか
難しい言葉で keystone 週間言います
keystone 習慣っていうのは
ある一つの行動を変えることで
生活全体に影響を与えるようなそういう習慣のことを言うんですね
村木君の場合はお昼食べ過ぎないということがそういうことでした
そして多くの人の場合はそれは食べることであったり睡眠を変えることであるという
ことが知られています
だからみんなも将来自分を変えたいなぁと思うことが出てくると思います
そういうときは何か突然思い立って新しいことをやるんじゃなくて
毎日二普段自分が当たり前にやっていることをちょっとずつ書いていく
そうすることで自分が変わっていくんだということですね
覚えておいてもらえるとお兄さんはとても嬉しいかなというふうに思います以上で僕の
話終わりますありがとうございました
ありがとうございます